In my blood test, the NK cells are 228, the range is 70-760.
When the number is closer to the higher range,
does that mean the immune system is better
or it is fighting something or some kind of infection?
That is why the number is higher,
save with a CD3 to CD16 ratio.
Yes, so when you look at...
That is the problem when you look at a differentiation.
Usually if you do CBC with a differential,
it is only going to measure neutrophils.
The differential is breaking down to the white blood cells
and lymphocytes, neutrophils, monocytes, blah, blah, blah.
It is not going to break it down deeper into NK cells,
which are natural killer cells.
And all the other CD cell line,
unless you do a deep dive in it.
There is argument whether the deep dive
with a value of the deep dive.
I don't recommend it even though one of the best tests for that
is a Syrex.
I forgot what it is, Ray 23.
I think it is.
That does the deep dive into that.
But that would really be for immune dysfunction patients.
That would be autoimmune issues.
Not really even beneficial for cancer patients.
And the reason is that, yes,
you can have elevated or suppressed immune function most likely
due to either current infection or an autoimmune disorder.
So having 220 ate, you're right in the middle.
That's normal.
It would only be, you know, you could take all the immune...
You could take bottles of immune stimulating supplements
and it's probably not going to increase your natural killer cells.
Because your body has a balance of what it's trying to achieve.
You can't artificially change that.
Because you're fighting a disease.
So you can support it so that your body can make.
So it's not depressed so that it's not...
So it's able to keep up the demand that your body's making.
But you can't just take a whole bunch of immune stimulation
and think that your white blood cell count is going to be...
is going to be elevated by simply doing that.
So no, it's usually because you're fighting something
or it's maybe you could also be in a hyper response
in an autoimmune situation.
Or if it's suppressed, depressed,
you could have a suppressed immune situation.
Also, you can't forget that you have to correlate to any medication
that you're taking.
Because medication can affect your bone marrow in production
of white blood cells as well.